on vous propose maintenant une pause des
tendances eux 7,8 sport c'est une
discipline du corps et de l'esprit
pratique et par de nombreux people et
sportif focus sociaux sur le hatha yoga
avec vous aurez lire 11 pour soir alors
que signifie le hatha yoga
alors le yoga est une école de
philosophie indienne le art de ata veut
dire soleil et le tas signifie lune
le hatha yoga en fait c'est l'union du
soleil et de la lune c'est en fait le
yoga traditionnel idéal donc pour la
détente et pour la paix intérieure
alors il existant dans les yvelines de
nombreuses associations et qui propose
des cours nous avons assisté à celui
proposé deux fois par semaine au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
par l'association souffle de vie une
discipline vous allez l'entendre qui a
de nombreuses vertus
ça va apporter déjà un équilibre du
corps et de l'esprit
donc pour vraiment être bien équilibrée
dans sa vie et au delà de ça donc ça
permet d'assouplir le corps d'étirer le
corps donc ça résout pas mal de
problèmes de douleur chronique ou de
problèmes physiques et en même temps
bien sûr ça des grandes vertus
relaxantes pour se détendre donc anti
stress et aussi donc ça a des vertus de
conscience de soi
combien de temps dure une séance
l'association souffle de vie propose l
des séances d'une heure et demie elle
est composée d'un temps de recentrage un
temps d'échauffement un travail sur la
respiration un échauffement spécifique
pour la posture de la séance également
déséquilibre et pour terminer 15 minutes
de relaxation et de méditation qui peut
pratiquer le hatha yoga
alors les enfants les personnes âgées
enfants tout le monde peut pratiquer ce
sport même vomi quérir est un petit peu
raide 1 et patrice part c'est vrai c'est
pas faux on mélange tous les niveaux
donc c'est une personne que j'aimais
fait du yoga à une personne qui a de
l'expérience en rigolant reste toujours
des buts en apprend toujours on
approfondit toujours donc justement ce
jeu il ya des personnes qui peuvent dire
je suis pas sourd je peux pas faire du
non justement venez faire du yoga parce
qu'on s'assouplit on n'a pas besoin
d'être souple au départ on s'assouplit
on progresse
au long de vos fils du temps alors si
vous aussi vous voulez être zen voici
quelques informations pratiques sachez
que le tarif est de 210 euros pour par
trimestre pour un cours par semaine
c'est l'état riche en qui sont qui sont
pratiqués pour pour le yoga
il n'y a pas besoin de beaucoup de
matériel un tapis une tenue confortable
un plaide pour la relaxation un petit
poussin si vous avez par exemple la
nuque fragile à sachez que l'association
souffle de vie donne des cours à
montigny le bretonneux à maurepas
également à montfort l'amaury toutes les
informations sur le site qui s'affiche
en bas de votre écran
merci aurélie pour ses découvertes ça
donne envie d'essayer
et surtout pour voir par avant chaque
séance de yoga se termine par damas
ténacité